hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in letter 120 seneca is providing us
with a number of very helpful
clarifications about how the stoics
understood virtue and
indeed the highest good which can be
understood as living virtuously or the
virtues
or as happiness freedom all these things
that we put together smooth flow of life
but another way of talking about it is
as
the good or the honorable
in latin honestum and we're going to
come to that in just
a moment part of what's going on here
is he's bringing together a number of
different
important stoic doctrines about
not just virtues or the good
but how we human beings come to
recognize it and so i think this is a
particularly
useful and important letter
because it connects so many different
threads together
so he begins by
talking about the good in latin
bonum right in greek agathon and
the honorable honestum in latin the word
that we get honesty from and
you know that kind of falls into it but
it's not just about truth-telling
it's about what is intrinsically
valuable
onestum is a translation of what the
greek philosophers
called the the cologne which is a term
that could be used for the beautiful
or the fine or the noble the honorable
what it is that we we see as good
in a robust sense something that has
intrinsic value and that we recognize
as such now the stoics
held that the good
and the honorable are actually the same
so we're going to talk about what he has
to say in a moment
one thing i do want to point out is the
stoics viewed them according to seneca
as distinguishable distinguishable we
can actually
talk about them as different modalities
so they are
diverse in latin but they're not
different
they're not separated from each other
they don't have an existence on their
own
where something would be good but not
honorable or honorable but but not good
they are not
de visa in latin and he's going to
contrast this
to other philosophical views
and indeed the common sense views of
many
human beings where they do make other
things
good they will call them goods and the
stoics would say well
you can call them good but they're not
really good so you're misusing that
term here's here's what he uh gives us
an example the good for some people is
just what is
useful utile in latin and thus they
apply the term to wealth
to a horse to a wine to a shoe
you know and these things are useful
right i mean wearing shoes is nice you
can get around you don't stub your toes
the gravel doesn't hurt your feet right
in the case of myself
who has to wear orthotics it helps me
not feel bad in my body to wear shoes
wine can be useful for all sorts of
things from
getting drunk and having fun to a
marinade to you know
uh making a sacrifice we could go on and
on wealth
useful for all sorts of things and he
says so little do they value the good
and so far does it descend among menial
things
the honorable they think is what accords
with the reasoning of a fully
appropriate
action such as caring devotedly for an
elderly father assisting a
poverty-stricken friend
campaigning bravely delivering a
sensible and well-balanced policy
statement
and by appropriate action that's that's
a one way of translating the latin word
efficient which we also translate as
duty
so it's not that these people don't
recognize
that there is the honorable and that you
know could
be about fulfilling duties or engaging
in fully appropriate actions doing
good things that are actually
intrinsically good
but then they add other things in there
as being good and so he talks about
utility
we might also talk about pleasure if
we're thinking about the aristotelians
the aristotelians actually said
following aristotle
that there are a number of different
kinds of goodness there's the cologne
the
the
good that's you know beautiful there's
the
uh the useful right there's
also the pleasurable there's the just
all of these are different modalities
and they may overlap to some degree
the stoics say no no no that's not the
case
only the good is honorable only the
honorable is good
that's one of their slogans you could
say
so he says nothing is good unless it's
honorable what is honorable is
necessarily good
i judge it to be superfluous for me to
add what is the difference between these
because i've mentioned
frequently so you can read through his
other letters the point
it i will state here is that nothing is
good that can be used
badly or wrongly or to do do injustice
he says you see how many people make bad
use of wealth
social rank physical strength we could
talk about wine we could talk about
sexuality
we could talk about automobiles any any
sort of thing
can be misused if it's not a genuine
good
but can you misuse virtue
now you know much later on emanuel kant
in his groundwork for the metaphysics of
morals
will seem to be going a stoic path but
then say well you can also use
what you know we could call the virtues
wrongly so
the bandit who is courageous right
the person who has great mental powers
can use them wrongly
the stoics would say you're wrong kant
if it's genuine courage it's not going
to be used wrongly if it's genuine
wisdom or prudence
it's not going to be as drawingly so
there's an important
distinction there then he talks about
something else that the
stoics had a very interesting position
on
and he goes into some useful discussion
particularly when we correlate this
with other stoic discussions like that
for example put in
cato's mouth by cicero in
on the ends book three where a similar
thing is being said
here's the question how did we get our
conception
of the good or the honorable
does it just arise out of the fact that
we have certain inclinations
for instance to maintain ourselves in
existence
or to create new versions of our our
species and then to take care of them
or to associate with each other into
groups and and you know live out a
certain common life
the stoic said no not
exactly this is not coming directly from
nature although it's not
against nature and actually on a higher
level fulfills the potentialities
of our nature we human beings are
capable
of a certain ascension let's call it or
if you like an old-fashioned term a
quantum leap
from one level of valuing and choosing
and appropriating up to a higher one
that's incommensurable with it
so he tells us that nature itself did
not
teach us this conception of the good or
the honorable
it's not that nature doesn't teach us
what's good for ourself in
another sense and like being useful
maintaining our existence
or pleasurable but the good in this
sense
is not something that nature itself
could teach us
because nature doesn't provide us with
knowledge of that sort
as he says it just gives us the seeds of
knowledge so this is
a nice metaphor for nature
it's not totally disconnected from this
but this goes beyond
nature and he tells us that
[Music]
some people say we merely happened upon
the conception
but it's beyond belief that anyone would
have stumbled across a notion of virtue
by chance and here
you know this is worth actually
reflecting on how the hell would you
know what it is
if you don't have any clue about
what virtue is how would you how would
you recognize
it in all of these myriad things in our
experience
seneca puts forward a different theory
of a different kind of process so he
says that we
arrive at it by observation and
comparison of actions
now notice again what is he saying there
and what is he not saying there
we don't just like look within ourselves
and
detach ourselves from the world and then
reason about
you know what we're encountering in the
the space within
no we're actually looking at other
people
some of whom may be people we know and
some of whom may just be people that
we've heard of
and we say wow what is that what is
going on there this is really something
awesome and then we start comparing them
and we're like well
that person did something quite good by
comparison to the rest of us
rum nums who are you know just kind of
getting by
and we're going to look at a few
examples that he provides in just a
moment
so he says that in the judgment of our
school
they're understood by analogy and he
says
this term analogy came to us from the
greeks it's been naturalized by latin
scholars
so i think we should use it i will use
it not only as legitimate but fully
established let me explain what analogy
is
and here he gives you an example of an
analogy maybe
an analogy of an analogy if you want to
get a little meta
uh at this point he says we knew about
bodily health
from this we figured out there also
exists a health of the mind
so we've got several terms there right
health
body mind and then we say okay what is
the
analog what is the thing that would have
the same sort of
function or role or whatever whatever
meaning we're attributing to it
in the mind as it would be in the body
and we might do this in reverse and say
what are the things that go wrong with
the body and he actually gives you a
whole list a little bit later
in the letter of things that go wrong
with our bodies then we can say well
what are the things like that that go
wrong with the mind and what makes them
bad for the mind well
the things that are bad for the body are
the things that impede our natural
functions right or
go too far don't go far enough right so
things like that with the mind now he
doesn't spell that out for us here but
we can easily
fill that in he says certain acts of
generosity or humanity or courage had
amazed us
they struck us and we're like wow
what what is going on there and so
that's that's part of how we draw these
conclusions
and he says we began to admire them as
though they were perfect but there were
in fact many flaws
in them hidden by the brilliant
appearance of some splendid deed these
we overlook
nature tells us to magnify praiseworthy
actions
and everyone carries glorification
beyond the facts this was
thus it was from these acts that we
derive the notion of a mighty good so
there's a
there's a sort of fictitiousness here
isn't there
that seneca is acknowledging we actually
go beyond when we're looking at these
these virtuous people
we go beyond the the actual case and
that allows us to
grasp a possibility for us that isn't
actually being realized in these people
that were dazzled by
but does become a possibility for us
if we build upon it and so let's look at
some of these examples now
he brings up fabricus fabricus was
one of the people who is involved
against
king pirus who you probably haven't
heard of other than the notion of pyric
victory which you can look up
papyrus of appearance was
one of the rivals of the romans and the
carthaginians
and some of the other greeks in the time
when rome was
on the rise and there was a good
possibility that papyrus
could have established his own empire
and
and dynasty and history would have been
quite different he was an outstanding
individual and
one of the people who is involved with
pirates
his doctor offered fabricus this roman
the chance to use the doctor to betray
him
to betray pirates he offered to poison
him what did fabricus do
instead of saying yeah that sounds good
at all's fair in love and war right
he turns the information over to pyrus
and says listen
i'm going to fight against you buddy but
i just want to give you a heads up this
doctor of yours is trying to kill you
and he reached out to me and said would
you like me to uh
to help you out with this sort of thing
now that
is an act of virtue
we so he says both actions show the same
strength of character
not to be won over by gold not to win by
poison we admired a great man one who is
swayed neither by the offers of the king
nor by offers made against the king a
man who struck
who stuck by his own good example and
did what is hardest of all
in that he maintained his integrity even
in war
believing that even an enemy can be
wrong so he gave us an example
of what what human potential looks like
when it's realized does that mean that
fabricus was perfect in every way no no
it doesn't mean that at all according to
seneca
but we look at that that particular
example he gives you know several others
as well um hortius cook lace
blocking a narrow bridge against the
enemies of rome
uh all by himself showing you know
incredible bravery and he says these
and similar deeds gave us a picture of
virtue
and so now notice this it's not by
simply generalizing about virtue
seneca thinks that at least at the
starting points
we actually need what we can call role
models
we need examples of people who stand
above
and do things that are human and show us
the potentiality of humanity that goes
beyond
our own media you know mediocre or milk
toast
uh lack of virtue and
charts out a possible path for us
so they're still flawed of course but
that that's not that uh essential here
he also then tells us okay we do also
carry out a
sort of analysis of virtue we divided
this virtue into parts
the stoics recognized for cardinal
virtues wisdom
or prudence justice temperance or
moderation or self-control
and courage or bravery each of these
encompassed
subordinate virtues which you can read
about in aries didymus or you know in
other places
in the stoics as well and so what
is what differentiates this why have
more than one virtue
well he tells us it was right that
desires should be curbed
temperance fears checked courage
actions performed intelligently wisdom
and each person rendered his due
justice so we grasped these different
things and assigned to each its
own proper function so he says from
what then did we gain the understanding
of virtue that that person's orderliness
revealed it to us their seem
seemliness and consistency the harmony
among all his actions the greatness and
surmounting everything
it was thus that we came to understand
happiness the life that flows smoothly
and is completely under its control
and then he goes on a little bit further
and it's worth reflecting very briefly
on this he says
how then did this very point become
evident to us the sort of unification of
the virtues is a possibility
the perfect man the one in possession of
virtue never cursed his luck never
reacted to circumstances with a grim
face believing himself to be a citizen
and soldier of the world
he took on each labor as if it was a
command
he treated no incident as an annoying
nuisance and misfortune
but as a task assigned to himself and
here we have sort of the
portrayal of the stoic sage
arguably socrates fits the bill for that
and there may be some other figures as
well
now the the last important question
that we want to think about that
seneca's providing us with some great
answers to is
why are some people not virtuous
including perhaps ourselves why
why haven't we made this the centerpiece
of
our existence and there's really two
main things that he talks about here
one is you know sort of a difficulty
that arises because
of virtue he says that
some virtues and vices border on one
another
and in people who are depraved and
dishonorable there's some likeness to
rectitude
so what are some examples of this a
spendthrift person
gives the false impression of being
generous even though there's a huge
difference between them
spent thrift means somebody who's we
often say prodigal they spend everything
they're you know careless with their
money that's not the same thing as being
generous
he also says carelessness can look like
good nature
temerity like courage and he says
this similarity compelled us to take
thought and distinguish things that are
close in appearance
but immensely different in fact in
observing those who'd become famous for
doing an outstanding deed
we began to notice the sort of person
who did something with nobility and
great zeal
but once only right so we're seeing a
person who
can't as we would say nowadays transfer
bravery from one area to another area or
temperance from one area
to another area of justice from one area
to another area
so some people get mixed up about the
virtues and vices
and they think that just because a
person does a virtuous action once
they're virtuous right
or because they do a vicious action once
they're they're you know irr
irremediably vicious
so that that's one big problem right
there
the other thing that he brings up and
he's touched on this already a little
bit
is a certain kind of instability a
virtuous person
is consistent in virtue
so he goes on and he tells us that
here we go when we saw a person with his
strength of character
how could we not get a notion of a
remarkable disposition
especially if its consistency showed it
to be genuine greatness
truth is stable and consistent
false things do not last so there's
there's a bit of
time required to determine whether
somebody really is virtuous
now here's where it gets really
interesting he says that
some people are
vatinitus and cato by turn
sometimes they find curious
insufficiently austere
fabricus not poor enough and to bear a
lacking forget frugality and modest
living
other times they compete with lacienus
and wealth a piccious and gourmet dining
and macon us in refinement so what they
you know he's bringing up a lot of
people who you may not actually know but
suffice it to say some of these are
examples of great virtue
some of these are examples of great vice
and what he's saying is
sometimes people think hey i'm going to
be like i'm not just going to like
rival socrates man i'm going to be
better than him
and they forget that it takes a long
time to become a socrates you can't just
turn it on or something like that right
and then the next moment
or the next hour or the next day they're
taking a cheat day
and they're like stuffing their face
like a piccius
or they're you know doing all sorts of
other things that they're not supposed
to be doing that are
if they want to live a life that that's
virtuous and so
he talks about us as
you know he says the best evidence of a
bad character is variability
and constant shifting constant shifting
between what
pretense of virtues and love of
vices a person who
doesn't have a fixed character
except in the sense that you can you can
count on them to
pretend to have virtue every once in a
while to have virtue
to develop it to follow it that's a
lifelong task
seneca speaks in other places about
virtue is something
sort of like when you dye fabric you
can't just dip it in once you've got to
be continually doing it until it sticks
till it holds fast
so there's a lot of people who fluctuate
between you know the vices that they're
indulging
and pretending or yearning for virtue
and the reason why they can yearn for
virtue
is there's still some recognition of its
goodness
they're drawn to it they're attracted to
it they just can't realize it
in themselves because they're still
giving priority to those vices so if we
want to become virtuous
we actually need to figure out you know
who
who our role models are how we want to
be and do some thinking about this
and probably some study and then we have
to make a decision to have our life
be one of consistency
you